hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with another hd video
and today we're going to talk about the
canon 5d mark iii
or 6d rumors basically this camera
doesn't exist yet we're just going to
talk about what we know about it so as
you guys probably already know the canon
5d mark ii is a top-notch hd video
shooting dslr it was actually the first
dslr to shoot hd video from canon and uh
it's an amazing camera but we are
starting to wonder what canon's gonna do
with the refresh it's interesting
because the 5d mark ii has actually
become a very popular just video camera
a lot of people use it just to shoot
videos there are tv shows that use it to
shoot video so we're kind of thinking
the refresh is going to be a more video
centered refresh and i think some of the
things we could expect is maybe
something like a slightly larger lcd
screen on the back maybe even an
articulating lcd screen like we see on
the 60d something cool to see on the
mark iii would be a dual memory card
slot right now it only has a single
memory card slot and it's a cf card i
think it'll still be another cf card but
if there is a dual memory card slot and
you could also film more than four
gigabytes per clip of hd video that
would be really nice in the upgrade now
for photographers one of the biggest
deals about the 5d mark ii was a less
than perfect autofocus system it's
really
it's very very much surpassed by the
likes of maybe the 50d or the 7d that
have a much faster autofocus system as
you can see it's not exactly slow but it
still could use some work so we were
thinking that the 5d mark iii might have
a better autofocus system but then we
realized that would kind of take away
from reasons to buy their other dslrs so
as much as we'd like to see better
autofocus in the mark iii
i don't think it's going to happen this
time other things like the beautiful
body of the 5d mark ii will be probably
preserved in the mark iii it's a weather
sealed body and all the l lenses are
weather sealed so they're a very nice
mount a very nice pair i think it'll
also be paired with the 24 to 105 f4
again great kit lens and i think it's
definitely a great all-around
walk-around lens it works really well
with the 5d especially because it's full
frame so the processor in the 5d mark ii
is the digic 4 processor and you can
shoot it up to 3.9 frames per second i
think the 5d mark iii is going to have a
slight bump in that i don't know if it's
going to be a digi 5 processor or maybe
two digit 4 processors but i think that
there's going to be a frames per second
boost maybe to about 4.5 4.8 frames per
second it's not exactly slow right now
but it could use a little bit of work i
think the biggest possible upgrade that
we could see to the mark ii is the
sensor there has been some crazy rumors
flying around of the mark iii maybe
having close to like a high 20 to low 30
megapixel sensor so we've we've seen a
rumor of the 36 megapixel sensor in the
canon that that's pretty crazy i know it
sounds like the noise performance would
be bad but the 5d mark ii has excellent
low light performance with a 21
megapixel sensor so i'm interested to
see what canon does but right now i'm
going to put my estimate at a 32
megapixel no i'm going to say 28 i'm
gonna say 28 megapixel sensor in the
mark iii i have no idea what the release
date is going to be i'm going to leave
that speculation up to you guys but i
think that when it does come out we
could we can expect to see prices of the
mark ii drop a lot they they started off
around 2 800
and right now you can pick up a 5d mark
ii body for about 19 1800 on ebay and if
you'd like to rent one for a couple of
weeks for a much much better price you
can check out the link in the
description where you can buy all sorts
of camera gear video gear maybe you have
a shoe coming up you want to shoot crazy
videos for a week you can rent a 5d so
that's basically it guys thanks for
watching this video and if you enjoyed
it please give it a thumbs up there's a
lot more videos to come and a lot more
reviews also to come of products that i
haven't even showed you guys yet
and if you enjoyed also please subscribe
if you haven't already thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys later
peace
[Music]
you